colima y guanajuato son dos ciudades que
pueden producir dos bienes flamantes
collares y frutos del bosque lo sé son
encantadores los mundos que inventamos
para hablar de estos temas en economía
la siguiente tabla describe las
posibilidades de producción de cada
ciudad en un día aquí nos indica que si
colima pone toda su energía en collares
puede producir diez collares en un día
pero si pone toda su energía en frutos
del bosque puede producir 20 frutos en
un día y si guanajuato pone toda su
energía en collares produce 25 si la
pone en frutos del bosque produce 75
dado que estos números se basan en que
ambas ciudades tienen la misma cantidad
de trabajo y capital quien tiene la
ventaja absoluta en collares recuerden
que la ventaja absoluta únicamente se
refiere a quién es más eficiente quien
con los mismos insumos puede producir
más se nos indica que ambas ciudades
tienen la misma cantidad de trabajadores
y capital por lo que realmente sólo es
cuestión de quién puede producir más
collares en un día y podemos ver muy
claramente que guanajuato es la ciudad
que puede hacerlo vamos a escribirlo
cuando produce más collares por día con
los mismos insumos porque es más
eficiente con sus recursos entonces
tiene la ventaja absoluta esto es
interesante porque podríamos intuir que
la ciudad que tiene la ventaja absoluta
es quien debe producir los collares pero
cuando estudiamos la ventaja comparativa
vemos que no siempre es así y sospecho
que la siguiente pregunta nos va a
llevar a eso muy bien se nos pide
calcular el costo de oportunidad de los
collares en colima cuando colima decide
producir 10 collares está dejando de
producir 20 frutos del bosque porque ha
puesto todos sus recursos en la
producción de collares otra manera de
plantearlo sería que le cuesta 20 frutos
del bosque producir 10 collares lo que
es igual a 2 frutos por collar ese es su
costo de oportunidad vamos a poner una
pequeña columna aquí con el costo de
oportunidad que es de 2 frutos del
bosque por collar si van a hacer un
examen por ejemplo un examen a p no es
mala idea llenar todo esto entonces cuál
es el costo de oportunidad de los
en guanajuato todavía no nos lo piden
pero vamos a calcularlo rápidamente para
producir 25 collares guanajuato está
dejando de producir 75 frutos del bosque
esto sería 75 dividido entre 25 lo cual
nos da 3 frutos por collar y si queremos
conocer el costo de oportunidad de los
frutos simplemente podemos tomar los
recíprocos entonces en colima el costo
de oportunidad es un medio de collar por
fruto del bosque y en guanajuato es un
tercio de collar por fruto del bosque si
quiere producir 75 frutos del bosque
tendría que dejar de producir 25
collares así que le costaría 25 collares
producir 75 frutos del bosque o un
tercio de collar por fruto sólo estamos
haciendo unos cuantos cálculos extra
pero nos van a ser útiles porque de
hecho en la siguiente pregunta se nos
pide explicar quién tiene la ventaja
comparativa en frutos del bosque la
ciudad que tiene el costo de oportunidad
más bajo tiene la ventaja comparativa y
aquí podemos ver que guanajuato tiene el
costo de oportunidad más bajo en frutos
del bosque
es menor que un medio por lo que es un
costo de oportunidad más bajo para
producir un fruto del bosque
así pues guanajuato tiene un costo de
oportunidad de un tercio de collar por
fruto del bosque lo cual es menor que el
costo de oportunidad de un medio de
collar por fruto del bosque de colima
entonces
guanajuato tiene la ventaja comparativa
en frutos del bosque muy bien siguiente
pregunta si estas ciudades fueran a
especializarse en un solo bien y
comerciar entre sí explica cuál ciudad
produciría collares y cuál frutos del
bosque la ciudad que tiene la ventaja
comparativa en un bien producirá ese
bien
colima tiene el costo de oportunidad más
bajo en collares así que tiene la
ventaja comparativa en collares y ya
dijimos que guanajuato tiene la ventaja
comparativa en frutos del bosque
entonces colima produce collares y
guanajuato produce frutos del bosque
recuerden que esto se basa en lo que
hablamos al comienzo del vídeo aunque
guanajuato tiene la ventaja absoluta en
ambos productos y aunque puede producir
collares de una manera más eficiente que
colima si creemos todos los argumentos
de la ventaja comparativa en realidad
guanajuato debería producir los frutos
mientras que colima debería producir los
collares porque guanajuato tiene un
costo de oportunidad más bajo en
términos de frutos del bosque
ahora respondamos la última pregunta qué
precio comercial podrían acordar
guanajuato y colima para comerciar
collares tal vez se pregunten qué es un
precio estamos acostumbrados a hablar de
ello en términos de pesos o algún otro
tipo de moneda pero como damos un precio
aquí la clave es que podemos dar un
precio en términos de costos de
oportunidad se nos pide un precio de los
collares que en realidad podría ser en
términos de frutos del bosque examinemos
cada uno de los costos de oportunidad en
collares en colima el costo de
oportunidad de un collar es de dos
frutos por collar en
cuarto es de tres frutos por collar
vamos a anotarlo por aquí el costo de
oportunidad en collares en colima es de
dos frutos del bosque por collar y el
costo de oportunidad de los collares en
guanajuato es de tres frutos del bosque
por collar con esto vamos a entender por
qué funciona la ventaja comparativa
dijimos que colima tendría que enfocarse
en los collares si puede venderle
collares a guanajuato por algo que sea
mayor que su costo de oportunidad y
menor que el costo de oportunidad de
guanajuato ambos se beneficiarán
supongamos que para ellos un buen precio
sería la mitad aunque en realidad podría
ser cualquier cantidad intermedia
entonces el precio sería de 2.5 frutos
del bosque por cada collar y ambas
ciudades se beneficiarán si comercian a
ese precio porque esto tiene sentido
para guanajuato aunque es la ciudad con
la ventaja absoluta porque hasta este
punto sin importar lo que haga cada
collar le costaría 3 frutos del bosque
pero ahora ha descubierto que por medio
del comercio puede obtener collares a
dos y medio frutos del bosque por collar
y esta es una mejor situación para
guanajuato
cosa que hay que entender cuando
hablamos de ventaja comparativa es que
algunas personas piensan que se trata de
que una ciudad se beneficie más que la
otra pero si asumimos todas las
suposiciones de nuestros ejemplos acerca
de la ventaja comparativa en realidad
son ambas ciudades las que están
comerciando beneficios ambas saldrán
beneficiadas
ambas obtendrán ganancias del comercio y
ambas estarán en una mejor situación nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo